اريد
لا اعرف حقيقه ما حدث تحديدا لكنني لست
متفاجئا لا يحدث اي شيء في روسيا من دون
علم بوتين الخلل الفني لا يمكن ان يفقد
الطائره عن شاشه الرادار فورا والطائره
فقدت الخلل الفني لا يمكن ان يقطع الاتصال
مع قائد الطائره والاتصال قطع اذا الخلل
الفني خارج الحسابات حادث عرضي ام انتقام
للخيانه الكرم لن يعلنوا نهايه بريجوجان
وجزار بوتين يعفى من مهمته فما علاقه
فاجنبي الامر وروسيا تضم منطقتين جديدتين
من دوله المجاوره ولكن ليست من اوكرانيا
جال العجب ومواجهه
مباشره بين روسيا وامريكا وتركيا فوق شبه
جزيره القرم واردوغان يعلنها
نحن حليفه بوتين وبريطانيا تدفع
245 مليون دولار لشراء نووي الاوكراني وفي
السودان اندلعت حرب سلاح المدرعات
فلمن ستكون الغلبه الجزائر تتحرك لانهاء
ملف النيجر فهل يفعلها ابناء تبون
نهايه الخيانه لقد قالها سابقا وها هو
اليوم يفي بوعده ونحن نعلم ان بوتين لا
يخلف وعوده فيا لهم النهايه مؤلمه
ليفجنبريغوجان نعم بوتين اصدر حكمه الاخير
وقائد فاغناري يلقى حتفه لكن بغموض هذه
المره وبين الصدفه والانتقام تختبئ حقيقه
النهايه فهل يكون بريجو جان عبره لكل خاء
هنا اعلنت وكاله تاسر روسيه للانباء بمقتل
عشره اشخاص اثرى تحطم طائره خاصه شمال
موسكو وقالت هيئه الطيران المدني الروسي
كان على قائمه ركاب الطائره التي تحطمت في
مقاطعه فير ويمتلك بريجوجان مجموعه من
الشركات بما فيها الشركات متهمه بالتدخل
في انتخابات الرئاسه الامريكيه في عام
2016 ويخطعه وشركاته وشركائه لعقوبات
اقتصاديه واتهامات جنائيه في الولايات
المتحده وكان بريجوجن لم يكتفي بعداء
واشنطن وقد جعل من موسكو ايضا احد اعضائه
الذين تكاثروا في الفتره الاخيره وذلك بعد
انقلابه الفاشل في العاصمه الروسيه واليوم
بعد تحطم طائرته تفرق قدامه بين القبائل
فمن غير المؤكد ان كانت الولايات المتحده
هي من اسقط الطائره ام انه انتقام من
بوتين الذي اعتبر انقلاب فاجنار خيانه
وفوتا لا يتاخر عن الرد على الخيانه ولكن
مهلا مهلا فبرغم تحطم طائره بريجوجل
ونهايه كل ركابها غير ان وفاه قائد فاجنر
غير مؤكده حتى اشعار اخر فبرايكم هل تم
اغتيال بريجوجل ام انه تعرض لحادث بالصدفه
ام ان
كالقط بسبعه ارواح انتقام الرئيس الروسي
الانقلاب الاخير شمل قائدا اخر غير
بريجوجل انه الجنرال
الملقب بجزار بوتين او الجنرال
والذي قيل انه كان مشاركا في انقلاب
فيغنار اعفيه من منصبه واصبح قيد الاقامه
الجبريه ولا يمكنه مغادره مقر احتجازه
بحسب التقارير الغربيه وما يؤكد ذلك هو
قرار بوتين الاخير بتعيين رئيس الاركان
العامه للقوات الجويه الروسيه فيكتور
قائدا مؤقتا للقوات الجويه خلفا لسيرجي
سولفيكان يبدو ان بوتين طبق جرد نهايه
العام من اليوم وماذا بعد هل انتهت
التصفيه الى احداث الجو حيث معارك السماء
تتواصل لتعلن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
مقاتله روسيه اعترضت طائره استطلاع من
طراز ام كيو تسعه
قرب شبه جزيره القرم وفي منطقه اخرى اعلنت
الدفاع الروسيه ان مقاتله الروسيه من طراز
29 اعترضت طائره حربيه نرويجيه اقتربت من
اجواء روسيا فوق بحر بارنيتس وفي الجو
ايضا كانت الدفاع الروسيه قد اعلنت اسقاطب
سياره وسط موسكو واثنتين بمنطقتين
في ضواحي العاصمه اطلقها نظام كييف في عمل
جديد استهدف موسكو واضافت الوزاره ان
طائره مسيره ثالثه تم تعطيلها الكترونيا
فاصطدمت بمبنى مجمع موسكو سيتي قائد
الانشاء من دون ان تتسبب في وقوع اصابات
في الاثناء قالت هيئه الطيران المدني
استانفت نشاطها بعد تعليق الملاحه فيها
لساعات بسبب الهجمات الاوكرانيه
بالمسيارات من جهته قال نائب رئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني
انه هجوما بطائره مسيره روسيه استهدف
ميناء اسماعيل على نهر الدانوب جنوبي
البلاد اسفر عن اتلاف 13 الف طن من الحبوب
كانت ستتوجه الى مصر ورومانيا وفي هذه
الاحداث المصادر هي من تتحدث من جانب اخر
قال نائب رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني
اوليكساندر كوبراكوف بانه هجوما بطائره
مسيره روسيه استهدف ميناء اسماعيل على نهر
الدانوب جنوبيه البلاد واسفر عن اتلاف 13
الف طن من الحبوب وهنا ياتي الرد الروسي
على هجمات كيا حيث اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ان موسكو لن تترك هجوم كياب على
منشات مدنيه في روسيا دون رد ليبدا الرد
باعلان الدفاع الروسيه عن فشل قوتك يا فيل
اخت على كافه المحاور وتكبدها خلال اليوم
الماضي 700 قتيل وعشرات الاليات العسكريه
وها هو المصدر يتحدث وها نحن ذا نتصفحه
امامكم في الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه
ومن روسيا الى تركيا وبطريقه غريبه ها هو
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان يقول ان
بلاده لا تعترف
بالضم بجزيره القرم واصفا هذا الضم بغير
الشرعي واكد اردوغان تماسك انقر بموقفها
الداعم لوحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه فهل اعلن
اردوغان بذلك خيانه صدي ام ان هناك ما
يطبخ من تحت الطاوله وبالعوده الى موسكو
حيث كشف رئيس روسيا السابق ورئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي
ان بلاده قد تضم منطقتي اوسيتيا الجنوبيه
وابخازيا الانفصاليتين في جورجيا بعد ضم
مناطق اوكرانيه وبعدها ذوذات اعلن وزير
الطاقه البريطاني جراند تشابس ان بريطانيا
ستقدم لاوكرانيا نحو 245 مليون دولار
لشراء الوقود النووي لمحطتها الذريه وذلك
لكي لا تضطر لندن للحصول على الوقود عبر
روسيا في المستقبل
الاحداث والتطورات بعد معارك ضاريه لثلاثه
ايام الجيش السوداني يعلن سيطرته على سلاح
المدرعات تصريح ياتي خلافا لاعلان سابق
لقوات الدعم السريع بالسيطره على المقر
بينما اعلنت الامم المتحده مقتل 60 شخصا
على الاقل واصابه نحو 250 اخرين وفرار 50
الف شخص من مدينه نيالا عاصمه ولايه جنوب
دارفور غربيه السودان دعت الولايات
المتحده كوريا الشماليه الى الغاء مشروعها
مرتقبه لاطلاق قمر اصطناعي مؤكده ان
اطلاقه لقرارات مجلس الامن الدولي افادت
راوترز نقلا عن وكالات الملاحه بتعليق
حركه السفن عبر مضيق الباسفور بعد تعطل
سفينه اغلقت المضيق وقررت السلطات التركيه
اغلاق مضيق الدردنيل امام حركه الملاحه
البحريه بسبب حرائق الغابات قال مبعوث دول
ايكوس الى النيجر الجنرال عبد السلام ابو
بكر انه متفائل بالتوصل الى حل سلمي
للازمه التي تصف بالنيجر وهنا قالت وزاره
الخارجيه الجزائريه ان الوزير عطاف
وبتكليف من رئيس البلاد عبد المجيد تبون
يزور نيجيريا وبينين وغانا للتشاور بشان
سبل حل الازمه الدائره في النيجر عقب
الانقلاب قال رئيس هيئه قناه السويس
المصريه ان الملاحه تعاود انتظامها في
الاتجاهين ياتي ذلك بعد بدء السلطات
المعنيه سحب سفينه تعطلت في القناه كما
قال متحدث باسم هيئه قناه السويس ان
المعاينه المبدئيه افادت بعدم وجود ايه
خسائر او حالات تلوث وكانت شركه مارين
ترافيكالتي لتتبع حركه السفن ذكرت ان
ناقله الغاز المسال
اصطدمت بسفينه لشحن النفط في قناه السويس
الليله الماضيه
[موسيقى]